here with more reaction former hawaii uh
congresswoman and democratic
presidential uh hopeful uh tulsi gabriel
i don't think you're a democrat anymore
i'm not even i'm i'm calling you an
independent uh
all right so
here we have two weeks before the
election this laptop shows up um it's
immediately dismissed by everybody oh
russian disinformation nobody looked
into it even 51
former intelligence officers oh that's
russian disinformation turns out to be
true the media lied the whole time
and i just outlined 12 separate
instances where we catch joe biden lying
saying repeatedly during the campaign
i've never talked to my son not one time
about his foreign business dealings yet
we have pictures with joe biden hunter
biden and some of his foreign business
partners so um
i can only imagine what the media
reaction would be if it's trump what do
you think this means for the bidens
especially now that a grand jury is
being asked about who the big guy is
that we know to be joe biden
uh well sean you know the biden family
corruption issue is a very very serious
problem uh i think as you point to all
of these examples uh it points to
actually an even deeper more serious
problem that that poses an existential
threat to our democracy and that problem
lies in the fact that you have the
mainstream media you have social media
you have google which is much bigger and
more powerful than social media and you
have the security state as you saw with
these 51 senior level intelligence
officials all working as the arm and
mouthpiece for the washington elite the
power elite
this is not a real functioning democracy
we see dictatorships that also have
elections but they have almost total
control over their media and it makes it
virtually impossible for any opposition
candidate to challenge and and win and
so when we look at what we're facing
here it's not so different they decide
okay biden's the guy that we want to win
here's the information that we want
voters to see we're going to shove away
and hide any information we don't want
them to see and then we as voters have
to make our decision about who we're
going to vote for or not vote for based
on what is essentially propaganda coming
from those in power this washington
elite this power elite and that is what
poses this existential threat to our
democracy that we all need to be very
clear-eyed that we're dealing with here
so we have zero experience hunter
getting all this money all these deals
with china a hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree 1.5 billion dollar deal
bank of china 30 million dollar uh deal
as chronicled by peter schweitzer
we know that he they got three and a
half million from a russian oligarch the
former first lady of moscow i know they
got enough money designated for a sports
car from a kazakhstan oligarch then we
have barisma paying hunter no experience
in oil gas energy or ukraine he's
getting paid millions is company and
then joe leverages a billion dollars of
our money says you're not getting it you
got six hours fire that prosecutor
that's investigating my son
uh or i'm headed home
and son of a bee they fired the guy
now that looks like a real quid pro quo
with joe to me and it looks like the the
biden family combined with all that
money from all these countries i have a
pretty good inclination that they know
all about hunter biden his crack
addiction his proclivity towards let's
say women of the night i'll clean it up
as best i can
and i believe that the president is
likely compromised am i wrong
this is a serious issue sean it has to
be investigated uh this kind of
corruption shouldn't exist within our
government unfortunately it does and it
has for a long time uh as we approach
the two the 2022 elections later this
year as we approach the 2024 election
what i what i really want to redirect
people's uh focus and attention on is
this fact that that you have the
washington elite that is essentially
controlling what we see and hear the
reason why this is important for us to
know is because we as voters have to be
able to sift through that propaganda in
order to try to find and recognize the
real truth and information and make that
best informed decision so that we can
get rid of these politicians who are
part of this establishment continuing to
to propagate this nonsense and this
insanity that is posing this real threat
to the existence of our actual
democratic republic
all right tulsi gabbard thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else